casi una semana después del terremoto de
haití
el colapso temporal se superpone al
habitual as y evacuan los helicópteros
estadounidenses a los heridos es por
aire la única alternativa de auxilio los
deslizamientos por las tormentas impiden
el acceso por carretera a desovar hay
muchos daños en infraestructuras
carreteras hay informes de muchos
heridos veo a muchos médicos yendo y
viniendo algunas comunidades aisladas en
lo alto de las montañas han sido muy
afectadas
esta falta de acceso complica hacer un
balance real de víctimas pero hay otros
factores como el tradicional apego de
los haitianos por sus muertos que hace
que no los quieran abandonar también la
disputa territorial las organizaciones
humanitarias desconfían de las pandillas
estas habían dado una tregua a
principios de semana sin embargo dos
médicos han sido secuestrados provocando
huelgas en algunos hospitales que se
suman a la falta de insumos hay una gran
necesidad de oxígeno en este momento
la demanda en los últimos dos meses
aumentó más del 200 por ciento y ahora
mismo no podemos producir ni vender
oxígeno la escasez y la dificultad
también llegan a las ayudas humanitarias
las cuales no son suficientes para todos
los afectados donde me ido con las manos
vacías porque al llegar a por la ayuda
me dijeron que no estaba incluida en la
lista de la organización
problemas que por desgracia son
costumbre en haití el país más pobre de
américa que vive un nuevo terremoto
después del de 2010 que dejó más de
200.000 fallecidos y un mes después del
asesinato de su presidente joven el mois
de mercenarios